today on the matt walsh show leftist
elites have a message for average people
suffering under these economic
conditions shut up and stop complaining
that is actually the message of verbatim
also the supreme court strikes down new
york's unconstitutional gun control law
biden unveils his brilliant plan for
driving gas prices down 60 minutes
claims that a six foot two inch 230
pound male rugby player has no physical
advantages over the females he wants to
compete against
canada bans plastic straws but where
does all of the plastic pollution in the
ocean actually come from hint it's not
coming from canada or the united states
for that matter in our daily
cancellation the tsa heroically saves
lives by confiscating bottles of water
and tubes of sunscreen and then brags
about it on twitter we'll talk about all
that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
well life is already complicated what if
getting term life insurance to protect
your family could be easy though fabric
has moved life insurance all online so
getting a policy that's right for your
family is not complicated at all fabric
was built specifically for parents to
help you manage your family's financial
future like a parenting pro stress free
fabrics new lower prices means
significant savings over other providers
with great policies like a million
dollars in coverage for less than a
dollar a day everything is on your
schedule with fabric because it's all
online less than 10 minutes to apply and
you can be offered coverage instantly
with no health exam required then just
personalize your quote to fit your
family's needs it's as simple as that
with fabrics online hub it's easy to
track your family finances all in one
place get affordable life insurance set
up your kids college savings plan and
even establish a rainy day savings fund
at the same time planning for the future
has never been easier than this there's
no risk to apply today fabric has a
30-day back guarantee and you can cancel
at any time protect your family with
term life insurance now in just 10
minutes apply today at meetfabric.com
walsh that's meet fabric dot com welsh
to start protecting your family today
m-e-e-t
fabric dot com slash walsh fabric
insurance agency policies issued by
vantislife not available in new york and
montana price is subject to underwriting
and health questions
if we could say that anything good has
come from the cavalcade of economic
catastrophes that we now face thanks to
the biden regime it's maybe the clarity
that the situation is offered the
clarity is not exactly worth the price
we're paying for it but you have to look
for silver linings anywhere you can find
them these days and this has certainly
been a clarifying moment
as regular people suffer from high gas
prices inflation other severe financial
strains the democrat party what used to
be seen as and still bills itself as
the party of the working man
has thoroughly demonstrated its total
disdain for working-class people and i
mean disdain in a dictionary definition
sense of the term to have disdain for
someone is to feel
that the person is unworthy of
consideration you may not be directly
trying to hurt them or maybe you are but
the general attitude is that the person
suffering is just irrelevant to you
and that's been the bite
administration's approach you've heard
over and over again over the past
few weeks and months from various
officials that the record high gas
prices are actually a wonderful
opportunity to switch over to electric
vehicles and other green transportation
options the pain you're feeling is worth
it in the long run as it may help their
cultural agenda help advance it they say
we heard a similar message in the summer
of 2020 when communities across america
were in flames devastated terrorized by
blm rioting and that was all okay said
the democrat elites from behind the
walls of their gated communities because
if your business has been looted or your
home burned to the ground it's all for
the sake of social justice you see so so
take heart
on gas prices we're told that the pain
is worth it
not just for the sake of healing mother
earth but also for ukraine
so biden yesterday took issue with
republicans who criticized him over gas
prices isn't it worth a few extra bucks
in the tank in order to help ukraine he
asks
so for all those republicans in congress
criticizing me today for high gas prices
in america
are you now saying we were wrong to
support ukraine
are you saying we were wrong to stand up
to putin
are you saying that we would rather have
lower gas prices in america and putin's
iron fist in europe
i don't believe that
yeah uh yeah that's that's what we're
saying now this is a false choice of
course the gas prices are not
putin's fault but putting that aside
biden asks if we'd rather have lower gas
prices instead of helping ukraine and
the answer that i give that most normal
americans give is yes absolutely
i would leave ukraine to defend itself
and take the discount at the pump
absolutely in fact i'd leave ukraine to
defend itself even if there was no
discount of the pump but give me the
discount and you've just sweetened the
deal
abso i don't have to think about it
is that selfishness no it's called
patriotism
because i prioritize american families
over ukrainian families
and gas prices are not some small petty
concern the average price of gas right
now is almost five dollars a gallon this
is devastating to working class people
but the alleged party of the working
class is so far removed from the working
class that it can't even conceive of why
gas prices are a major concern for
people who don't have the benefit of
taking a chauffeur service everywhere uh
they go i mean joe biden hasn't paid for
a tank tank of gas since since like ever
since cars were invented so he doesn't
understand why it matters so much he
actually thinks that working-class
people are happy to have less money to
feed their children if it means that
they can stick it to putin
and it's all for the best anyway biden
thinks because
as he also said yesterday the ultimate
goal is to take cars off of the roads
entirely
we're investing almost 100 billion
dollars in public transit and rail
for all the studies show
that it will take millions of cars off
the road and significantly lose
pollution if there's a serious
transportation system
available
yeah get the cars off the road uh reduce
pollution why alleviate suffering when
it presents such a wonderful opportunity
and besides the suffering really isn't
that bad anyway i mean everybody's just
exaggerating that was the message from
michelle singletary at the washington
post
when she appeared on msnbc yesterday and
launched into what just might be the
most out of touch and tone-deaf diatribe
we've ever heard on cable news and
that's quite a statement i realize the
competition is stiff
but i think this is at least in the
running for that title listen for
yourself
there's a new poll out by politico
morning consult that i think is quite
revealing it shows 38 percent of
americans say they would rather see a
recession than their the inflation that
we're dealing with i mean i read that to
mean more than a third of americans are
so pressed by what they're having to pay
for gas for food everyday items rent
that they'd rather see a recession is
that where we are right now
you know
i'm just going to say this and and and
if i get bang for it i don't care there
are there is a great deal of americans
where it is uncomfortable that they're
spending more but they are not going to
go under you know you you gotta stop
complaining when there's so many people
who literally the inflation rate means
they may only have two meals instead of
three there are americans who did
extremely well in the last two years in
the market you still have your job and
yeah it's costing you more for gas but
guess what you're still gonna take that
holiday that fourth of july vacation you
could still eat out so i'm gonna need
you to calm down and back off because it
feeds into this fear and then this fear
feeds into people making decisions that
creates the very thing that they're
fearful of and if you're in that
category
calm down stop looking at your portfolio
and you know what you can do with all
that energy help other people help put
some food on the table somebody else's
house because you have extra now the
other half of america
anything that we can do to help them to
get to the job that they need to keep to
put that food on their table those are
the folks that we need to concentrate on
and if they are responding to this
survey saying that they're afraid i get
that
but overall many americans are not
suffering as much as they think they are
amazing why do they always have such
annoying voices is the question so calm
down back off
you're not suffering as much as you
think you are
she says
now make no mistake she's not directing
this message at millionaires she says
that half of the country is still doing
well this is half of the country
overall overall we're fine she claims
quit your bellyaching
now tough talk like this is pretty rare
from the left
you're not suffering as much as you
think you are when's the last time
you've ever heard anyone in the left say
something like that
and there are many contexts when it
should be said and it certainly will not
be said
it's quite instructive to see just when
they start speaking this way and who
they are speaking to
when they do
this is the clarity the moment offers us
leftist elites are saying out loud on
camera the kinds of things they usually
only mutter under their breath or say to
each other when nobody else is around
so what drives this i mean what drives
this uh what is really just a disregard
for human suffering
as much as these people talk about lived
experience why don't they seem to
actually care much about other people's
lived experience so called
of course it has a lot to do with the
fact that these people live in a bubble
they're insulated they're walled off
from the average people whose lives they
seek to control and govern and
manipulate um
that's a part of it that's not the whole
story
the other part of the story is that the
rules of intersectionality
demand that they siphon out their
compassion based on race gender sexual
orientation and so on they can care or
pretend to care about certain protected
classes of people and certain favored
groups
but they have to be careful not to
accidentally express any concern for the
unfavored classes particularly straight
white men
they wouldn't want anyone to get caught
in the faux compassion crossfire
and then the other thing to keep in mind
is that this may be the most important
aspect
is that the left has no concept of
inherent human dignity um any
true compassion or concern for your
fellow man
must spring from your recognition of and
belief in your fellow man's human worth
and dignity
but there is no shared human dignity on
the left our worth is subjective
conditional
highly mutable subject to change
so all that's left then is to virtue
signal to put on a show of compassion
but when the circumstances really call
for it when the chips are down they turn
their back and tell us to stop whining
and to simply suffer for the greater
good which is to say
their own good of course
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know the recent rise in property
value has also created bigger targets
for home title fraud with this type of
identity theft a fraudster files for a
title transfer to a bogus id then they
sell the victim's property refinance it
or take out a loan against the property
when these second mortgages or loans are
left unpaid the thieves are nowhere to
be found of course and this is why it's
so important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives your personal information gets
exposed so often making it dangerously
easy for a cyber criminal to steal your
identity protect your identity then with
lifelock by norton it's never been
easier to do lifelock detects and alerts
you to potential identity threats that
you may not
have
be able to spot on your own like loans
taken out in your name if you do become
a victim of identity theft a dedicated
us-based restoration specialist will
work to fix it look nobody can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions in all businesses but it's
easy to help protect yourself with
lifelock identity theft protection
starts here join now and save up to 25
off your first year at lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com walsh for 25
percent off
okay we start with this democrats
democrats and republicans of course
waging their assault on the second
amendment with their quote unquote
bipartisan gun control legislation that
they've agreed to uh but the supreme
court at least
thanks to the conservative majority is
uh standing in the gap
um and we await now for these uh red
flag laws to make their way up to the
supreme court
so that you know clarence thomas and
company can have their say say in it but
for now we have this decision from the
supreme court uh we're still waiting on
um
we're still waiting on the roe v wade
decision so that was not announced today
i think it has to be tomorrow they
usually they make announcements they
announce their decisions on tuesdays and
wednesdays or rather tuesdays and
thursdays and they added an extra day on
friday and so i think the assumption
probably is that
as they've announced
their decisions in most of the cases
that they heard
for this um
uh this time around uh the assumption is
that they're gonna announce it tomorrow
and then skip out of town but anyway
this was this was um
uh this was a case that people were
waiting for um not quite as much as roe
v wade but still a really important case
and here is uh from npr they have the
report says the u.s supreme court in a
six to three opinion
ruled that new york's restrictions on
the concealed carry of firearms in
public
violates the second amendment the
opinion written by justice clarence
thomas
invalidates the state's requirement for
people to show proper cause to get
public carry licenses writing for the
conservative majority justice thomas
said
quote the exercise of other
constitutional rights does not require
individuals to demonstrate to government
officers some special need the second
amendment right to carry arms and public
for self-defense is no different new
york's proper cause requirement violates
the 14th amendment by preventing
law-abiding citizens with ordinary
self-defense needs from exercising their
right to keep and bear arms in public
meanwhile writing for the court's three
liberals justice stephen breyer wrote
quote in applying that approach to new
york's law the court fails to correctly
identify and analyze the relevant
historical facts only by ignoring an
abundance of historical evidence
supporting regulations restricting the
public carriage of firearms can the
court conclude that new york's law is
not consistent with the nation's
historical tradition of firearm
regulation
and of course what they're always
worried about is well the historical
at least in this case they're worried
about the quote-unquote historical
tradition and when they say historical
they mean over the past few years
um
what they're not so worried about is the
actual constitution itself
so
this is obviously the right decision
they're striking down this law in new
york which was not only unconstitutional
but absurdly unconstitutional
that in order to exercise one of your
fundamental basic rights as an american
which our founding fathers
found to be so important that they put
it at number two on the list
right behind the freedom of expression
freedom of religion freedom of speech uh
but in order to do that you have to you
have to
go to a government official and
demonstrate to their satisfaction
that you need to exercise it
and if you can't demonstrate it then
they'll allow you to have the gun
but you got to keep it at your house
where it is very often useless because
especially if you live in new york
if you live in the city uh
many of the dangers that you're going to
experience to your personal safety
that's you're going to experience those
dangers out when you're walking around
they might happen at home too but more
than likely they're going to be out in
public
so this gave this is great for the
government of course it gives that puts
them in the position of deciding
who is worthy of that kind of protection
because that's really what this comes
down to
right all people are equal but some
people are more equal than others george
orwell wrote in a animal farm
so
you have to demonstrate to the
government
that
not only are you do you fear for your
life and do you have a to their
satisfaction a good reason to fear for
your life but that your life is worth
this kind of extra protection
that was the law anyway but that law has
gone away
for now
we can say
all right let's move to this for this
this is kind of a set of headlines we
got here on the five headlines and we're
gonna have various examples of the
government being just totally useless
because that's always fun and of course
we have to start with biden
and we go back to this gas prices issue
and he had a lot to say about gas prices
yesterday all of it quite stupid
and um you know maybe i wasn't entirely
fair you know i said he doesn't he
doesn't care about bringing down the
prices to them this is an opportunity
really they're actually they're actually
happy that the prices are so high
because it's an opportunity to get the
cars off the road
but um that's mostly true but he does
have he had one idea at least for how to
bring the ass prices down he made an
attempt yesterday
and here it was
so let's be honest with one another
my message is simple
to the companies running gas stations
and setting those prices at the pump
this is a time of war
global peril ukraine
these are not normal times
bring down the price you are charging at
the pump to reflect the cost you are
paying for the product do it now
do it today
problem solved
i wish someone had thought of that just
go
just tell the gas stations to
put take the price down that's all
there's a problem of gas being expensive
then just say to the gas stations hey
make it not as expensive and then and
then they'll go oh okay well all right
oh you guys don't like what the hype the
high prices you don't like that no we
don't oh we didn't realize okay we'll
just
what price do you guys want for the is
it 250 is that good two dollars 50 cents
what do you want
he's calling on gas stations to go
bankrupt first of all it's what he's
actually calling on them to do
um by just saying yeah just bring the
prices down guys
maybe i'll have a similar strategy
during wildfire season come on fires
just stop burning okay
this is a this is a this is a difficult
time in america stop burning you don't
need to burn
but at least biden's analysis was better
than what we got from somebody else on
msnbc
who
for reasons that are quite unclear to me
broke out into song while talking i mean
these these people are losing their
minds that's it they just don't know how
to respond we've got a democrat regime
everything's falling apart people's
lives are much worse now under biden
than they were under trump there's no
denying it and these people are just
scrambling they don't know how to
respond
and this one guy at msnbc has gone so
insane that he just started breaking out
into song in the middle of his
of his analysis of the situation listen
and these are crazy times we're living
in to put it mildly robin um but but can
you just get it straight for me who's to
blame for the cost of of oil being so
high right now is it because of
president biden's policies or are there
other effects going on
did you see this back and forth between
biden and the ceo of chevron and kind of
his emotions and it was so touchy-feely
and i could see if the oil execs had
kind of more chill to them they'd be
like quit playing games with my heart
with my heart i mean it's hard
yeah apparently apparently it's very
hard out there
uh
i
what
not exactly sure what he was going for
there but uh i i think it's it's
mainly just as i said that they're
they're scrambling they don't they don't
know what to say what to do
um and it's
that's always going to be the case when
you've got a democrat administration
that's failing this miserably this
utterly
but even more so when
you consider that he's taking the place
of donald trump
i mean donald trump was literally hitler
right remember and he's the worst
president we've ever had according to
them and
uh he just he's made our lives so so
terrible but the
the left they had to spend a lot of time
during trump's administration
um especially
pre-covered right
trying to convince us that our lives
were being made worse by trump itself
and even during code actually
they had to convey to convince us that
trump himself was caught was was making
our lives worse
because it wasn't really obvious to
anybody and we were living our lives we
don't really see the connection
but with trump there with uh biden
rather there's a very clear connection
he got into office and things went to
hell it's pretty clear
and it's that has happened in ways that
affect people every single day
and they don't know what to do so
they're just
singing i guess that's that's the way to
go here's some more government
uselessness this report from the daily
wire says president biden's
administration will impose restrictions
on the amount of nicotine in cigarettes
and tobacco products the office of
information regulatory affairs a
division within the office of management
and budget
issued a statement on tuesday regarding
the proposal saying this proposed rule
is a tobacco
product standard that would establish a
maximum nicotine level in cigarettes and
certain finished tobacco products
because tobacco-related harms
primarily result from addiction to
products that repeatedly expose users to
toxins fda would take this action to
reduce the addictiveness to certain
tobacco products thus giving addicted
users a greater ability to quit
um
and it's kind of interesting to see them
doing this you know they're going after
not just cigarettes
um
continuing this war on cigarettes which
you know meanwhile
cigarette the rate of smoking of
cigarettes has declined dramatically
over the years which is good
and at this point if you're still
choosing to smoke i mean every no one
everyone knows what you're getting into
when you pick up a cigarette everybody
knows they've got it it's it's uh we all
as kids we sat through all the the psas
and everything all the warnings about
cigarettes and they've got the big
messages right on the the carton this
will kill you you will die
and um so people know what they're
getting into i think at this point
but also
while they've they're launching this
continued campaign against cigarettes
and then they throw in uh you know
e-cigarettes and vaping and those sorts
of things
meanwhile in a lot of american cities
now you know they're setting up
stations
for you to go and um
shoot up heroin
so
you know
the hard drugs
people are using those at record rates
and um even even marijuana i mean you
can't walk through a city anymore
without every city that i've been to
certainly over the last year
while we were filming what is a woman
you know uh many things it was a
revelatory experience going through all
these cities and talking to people
and part of it also was just the fact
that every single city everywhere just
reeks of weed everywhere you go
everyone's walking around high all the
time
and uh marijuana is the least of it
right along with all the other hard
drugs so that's happening not a lot's
being done to curb it in fact not only
are they not curbing it but in many of
these cities again they're actually
facilitating the use of these drugs
but they're going after cigarettes
and vaping because that makes a lot of
sense
speaking of things that make sense the
rugby league
has now banned males from competing
against females in international
competition
and 60 minutes australia did a story
about this
and i want to play this story for you if
you're only listening to the audio
you're not going to be able to fully
appreciate this because you got to see
the video so go to youtube or go
dailywire.com and watch the video too um
this is not supposed to be a parody
they interview hannah mountze who's a
male who identifies as a woman plays
rugby is now going to be excluded from a
lot of these competitions a lot of these
uh rugby batches
and
we you're supposed to watch this
interview and think that hannah mouzy
is the victim and that it's absurd
that he would be excluded
but it's kind of hard to come to that
conclusion just based on the visual
let's watch
do you accept the afl's argument that
you do have a size advantage over some
of your opponents i think the biggest
issue is not necessarily that i'm too
big or too strong now
it's more
okay
you're already big ready strong whatever
but what if you were to get into that
elite training environment
and
they would build you up put on an extra
15 kilos and you just push everyone
aside but physiologically that's just
not going to happen
the people who seem to have the biggest
problem with this is male administrators
but the female competitors haven't
raised their voices at all lisa watson
knows better than most what hannah's
going through she's a doctor who
specialises in transgender health issues
and is also a transgender athlete
after two years of hormone replacement
therapy she says hannah's body has no
residual benefits from her time as a
male
prior to her transitioning she had a v8
motor powering this
big muscle
frame
now she's transitioned and her
testosterone level has dropped and her
muscle mass has decreased and her
strength and
stamina has decreased she's now got a
little four-cylinder engine so she's
actually at a physical disadvantage
dr watson suspects there are other more
sinister factors at play
i'm just wondering whether they did not
want to have someone like hannah
representing their new league
they wanted
a presentable
beautiful
female who could be
the face of afl
a trans woman may not be what they
desired
okay i had to actually take notes
because there's so much nonsense here
that we need to pick apart in that uh
less than two minute clip there
um
first of all we'll start with the trans
person the other the older person saying
that uh well female competitors they're
not complaining
well yes they are complaining first of
all
uh they they have complained in all of
these sports
but then the other part of it is that
um it when if and when they do complain
they are shouted down and called bigots
by people like you
so you've got a metaphorical gun to
their head and then you're saying look
at that they're not complaining while
you point the gun right at their head
and you're muttering under your breath
to them you better not complain
you see they're not complaining
i mean if they do complain we'll destroy
their lives of course and uh it will
just rip them to pieces
but they're not complaining
no it's it's even in spite of that there
are still women who are
speaking out
and many more should and hopefully will
in the future
also we're told by
the um
the reporter there that hannah mountzee
has no residual benefits
and again you have to see the visual to
really appreciate this and in fact you
can go to google and just look up hannah
mounty and to see the the spectacle
of this guy competing against women in
rugby it's ridiculous like you would you
another thing from the left where when
you first see it you think it must be a
joke this must be from no it's this is
real hannah mouzy in spite of all the uh
the hormones presents and everything
else
hannah mouzy is
six foot two
hold on i just had it up here i want to
get i want to get hannah mouncey's
statistics okay
six foot two
220 pounds
no residual benefits in rugby against
women
what's the average um height and weight
of a of a of a female um five feet four
inches and 170 pounds
okay
five feet four on average
versus six foot two
220 pounds versus 170
on average
no residual benefits
it's just
it's just total absurdity the the truth
is right there in front of your face as
always
and they are and you're looking right at
it and they are telling you no that
doesn't exist it's like you're it's like
you're you're standing in front of a
brick wall
okay and hannah mouzy is basically a
brick wall compared to these uh to these
women that he's competing against
but it's as though you're standing in
front of a brick wall and actually
banging your head against it and they're
sitting there telling you oh that brick
wall doesn't exist no it doesn't it's
actually not there
then you're supposed to just accept that
okay
and then the other part of this too i
mean we could we could talk about
um
just how dishonest and disingenuous all
this is women aren't complaining yeah
but when they do you destroy them no
residual benefits that's ridiculous and
we can talk about all those issues
but also i don't want to gloss over
just the um
how they sort of casually admit
the ways that um
this gender so-called gender transition
destroys your body
so you have this other guy
just casually admitting this
oh well yeah he's been on all these
drugs and everything so there's a lot
weaker he's he's not as powerful
well he's no i assure you his body's
been destroyed
by by transition
and that's supposed to be a good thing
now i i
agree with that i don't deny that
they are correct that when you get on
the hormone drugs and everything else
and you start the transition you are
destroying your body
and you are whether you're a man or a
woman you are depriving yourself
of many of the benefits of being a man
or a woman
you're taking away a lot of the
inherent power that you would have in
that identity as a male or a female
you're stripping all of that away and in
return you're getting nothing
so a woman as she transitions
she takes away her female form her
breasts her ability to conceive children
all of that her feminine beauty all of
that is out the window
and in replace she gets nothing
she doesn't get the power and strength
of a man she doesn't even get the
appearance of a man
she doesn't get the biological
capacities and abilities of of a male
she gets none of that
so she's lost much of what makes her a
woman though she still is a woman and
she gets none of what makes a man a man
and she just ends up with nothing
so it's a bargain where you give up
everything and you get nothing in return
like a literal deal with the devil is
what it is and it's the same thing for a
man
and they admit that like we're
like they're proud of it like it's a
good thing
no what you're describing that's all the
more reason why this doctor should not
be doing this to people
and they get away with that
like
they can
most the time they will admit
or rather they will they will refuse to
admit that gender transition destroys
the body
the only time they'll admit it is in
this context
when they're trying to defend the idea
of males competing against females in
sports
and then they'll freely admit it and say
oh no his body's completely ruined i
assure you everything's fine
absolutely grotesque this is from cnbc
it says canada is banning the
manufacture and import of single-use
plastics by the end of the year the
government announced on monday and a
major effort to combat plastic waste and
address climate change the ban will
cover items like checkout bags cutlery
food service wear and of course straws
that's a big part of this
single-use plastics make up most of the
plastic waste
that we're told by cnbc and so all of
that uh
prime minister justin trudeau is gonna
be out the window you're not gonna have
any more of that
and uh you know you can as far as straws
go you can uh just make do with the
totally useless paper straws you know
paper straws which
you're taking paper and you're putting
them in water or in some kind of liquid
and then what happens when paper makes
contact with liquid
you know it starts to fall apart which
is what happens with the paper straws
now the thing about this a couple points
here
first of all the whole straw thing the
plastic straw thing
when did that start i started a few
years ago right we didn't hear anything
about about plastic straws nobody was
complaining about plastic straws and
then a few years ago there was this big
push to start banning plastic straws and
they banned them in california they
banned them in various different uh
states the united states and now they're
banning them in canada
well why did it start i mean why do we
start caring all of a sudden about
plastic straws of all things
uh well
that goes back to and you could still
see this statistic being bandied about
a few years ago if you remember we
started hearing all these reports
about how um americans i think it was
just americans the claim was
americans use 500 million
plastic straws a day
that was the actually let me clarify let
me look that up again to make sure i
have the exact claim
that they that they made yeah okay
500 million plastic straws every day
that's the claim
and i'm looking right now at the
national park service on their website
and they still have this claim up there
500 million plastic straws every day and
uh and that was the the jumping off
point for this
campaign to ban straws because 500
million plastic straws a day that's uh
it's astronomical it's unbelievable
right
um they're talking about billions over
the course of just not a few years
you're talking about you're talking
about billions and trillions and
trillions of straws
well here's the problem
that the 500 million straws a day
was a statistic
invented by a nine-year-old
a nine-year-old was doing some sort of
project for school and came up with this
idea that we use 500 million straws a
day and he and he came to this by doing
um a brief phone survey of a few people
and then from there the nine-year-old
extrapolated that we used 500 million
straws a day
and that claim which again was invented
by a nine-year-old is still used now
to justify banning plastic straws
the national park service has it front
and center right on their website
this has already been debunked it's like
there was
we should need to debunk it this is a
nine-year-old and i mean
all due respect to nine-year-olds
uh i have two two nine-year-olds myself
but i'm not gonna trust them with
statistics they're not very you know
when it comes to
to statistics they
uh i think lack some um some perspective
and of course we don't use 500 million
straws a day
how could we possibly
that's like every american
every single american is using almost
two straws every single day
meanwhile i think i've used like two
straws in the last 10 years of my life
who's using all these straws
but getting away from the straws for a
second because that's just totally
invented plastic straws are not really a
big problem uh they've got you look at
all the waste and and
garbage and everything in the pollution
and the litter plastic straws make up a
very small amount of it
i mean these days you know a lot of the
littering and waste a lot of that those
are the disposable
non-biodegradable masks that they had
everybody in for two years
not a lot of concern for the environment
with that
but with plastic in general here here's
a fact that everybody should realize
um
most of the plastic
in the
the world's oceans
comes from
asia and africa okay
in fact when it comes to plastic
pollution when i say most i'm almost
kind of understating it 95
of the problem
stems to asia and africa
and there are like 10 rivers in asia and
africa that account for almost all of
this
okay countries like china indonesia
vietnam thailand
um the philippines
and then countries in uh in africa too
uh
they they they account for 95 of the
problem
and it's not even just those continents
it's it's like 10 rivers in those
continents
create this problem and why is that well
because in some of these countries
they use their rivers like garbage
conveyor belts
and they just dump their trash
and their waste and their human waste
too and if
it funnels and flows right out into the
ocean
that's 95 of the problem
and that means that
all the rest of the world we have we
account for 5
of the plastic waste
you know the united states and our
entire hemisphere
accounts for less than five percent of
the problem
and of that five percent how many of it
how much of it goes back to plastic
straws
it's a lot less than one percent i can
tell you that
now does that mean that we should do
nothing at all does that mean that we're
completely off the hook does that mean
that we have a lot of ground to make up
so we might as well just start dumping
stuff in our rivers you know because
it's not going to make a difference
should we be doing that no of course not
we shouldn't be littering you should be
you know you should be uh
you should be responsible with your own
waste and your own garbage i totally
believe that
but if we're trying to make a dent
in the plastic pollution problem
especially as it affects our world's
oceans and it is a problem
if we're trying to make a dent in that
problem and address it then we cannot
exclude 95
of the problem
and yet that's what we do
because when's the last time you heard
an environmentalist say anything about
asia and africa and the way that they
contribute to this what they say is a
crisis
when's the last time you heard them even
mention it
because because you know in the united
states
we could
from this point forward
create zero waste if we could find a way
and maybe take all of our pollution all
of our waste all of our litter and just
uh launch it directly into the sun and
that's all we do from now on so we are
not contributing to the problem at all
even if we did that that would have
almost no effect whatsoever on the
overall problem
so if you actually want to do something
about it then you got to get you got to
get asian africa on board
and we got to start talking about the
fact
that in a lot of those countries on
those continents people are just
dumping
waste just mounds of garbage tons and
tons of garbage every single day into
the river out to the ocean
but of course we can't talk about that
because that's racist
all right one other thing here uh
senator cringe cory booker put together
perhaps one of the one of the cringiest
videos uh ever produced by a politician
and i thought that we would just watch
it together here it is
[Music]
okay they're running after each other
and tackling each other
really bad acting on display here
guys reporters are calling you're
tackling each other in the capital we've
been through this before you have to
stop tackling each other all right
then we'll just tackle big ag
consolidation
well a big egg consolidation is killing
rural america we need to get to work and
help the cow calf guys and the feeders
and the consumers take it at the meat
counter too that's why we introduced a
couple bills booker we need to get these
bills done we're going to get them done
man i appreciate you you're a good guy
okay oh my gosh
it was worse than i thought
all right we can stop that you take it
off
you know you can tell a lot about
somebody from their sense of humor i
think
because humor is one of the most
uniquely human things right and uh i
think humor is also a really good test
of iq
i think you don't even need all the
complicated iq tests
you could just uh someone just list for
me what you think the five funniest
movies of all time are something and i
could already i could get you i can i
can peg your iq
within a five point range just based on
that alone
and so what does that tell us about cory
booker let me keep that in mind
well he's very stupid and he's also
barely human
although i did appreciate this so uh
cory booker's fans who he has fans
uh they loved this video they thought it
was very hilarious and there was this
one tweet from someone
who said this is the funniest video
you'll ever see about anti-trust
legislation in the food and agriculture
industries
and you know what
she's right i mean i'll give i'll give
him that at least it is definitely the
funniest video i've ever seen about
antitrust legislation in the food and
agricultural industry so
gotta hand it to him at least for that
as we've already reviewed today on the
show gas prices are up and they're only
going to go higher and as far as the buy
administration is concerned you are on
your own
uh but luckily there is uh at least one
company looking to help it's called
upside it's the upside app my listeners
are earning cashback for every gallon of
gas every time they fill up just
download the free upside app in the app
store or google play right now use promo
code walsh for 25 cents per gallon or
more on your first fill up cash back
it's as simple as that don't pay full
price at the pump anymore get cash back
using upside just download the app for
free and use promo code walsh for 25
cents per gallon or more on your first
tank and it's not just for gas you can
you can get cash back at grocery stores
restaurants with takeout food as well
and you can cash out anytime your bank
account or an e-gift card for select
retailers and brands all upside no
downside just download the free upside
app and use promo code walsh to get that
25 cents per gallon or more cash back on
your first tank again that's uh
codewalsh with the upside app
now let's get to our uh comment section
[Music]
uh let's see noah
quoting me the latest celebrity trend is
to have a non-binary kid it's so
transparent
even if he didn't mean for it to be that
was one of the best puns i've heard in a
while
i did i want to claim credit for that
okay i did that was 100
intentional okay that was a pun intended
moment and i was pretty proud of it but
then i thought
it would be more effective if i don't
stop and ask for acknowledgement with my
transparent pun
but then after the fact i thought well
i don't know i think i played that too
cool and people are going to think i did
it by accident
so now i'm circling back to say
that yesterday i meant to do that with
the pun
and now it's just you don't even believe
you think i'm taking credit for it after
the fact and it's just really pathetic
and it's certainly not funny anymore
because i'm explaining it a day later
but still
nate soyboy says i'll be glad when matt
finally comes out as trans because this
self-hate is sad and exhausting to watch
well your username at least i think is
there's some accuracy there nate so i
appreciate that um i always find this
interesting from the left when they do
this thing you know if you're talking
about
uh
gender you're talking about
lgbt anything like that they say oh
you're only doing that because you're
you're really trans or you're actually
gay you're in the closet
well
so are you using those things as an
insult maybe i am trans nate
what of it
what is what's your point
you you mean it as an insult then
that's that's the really interesting the
only people anymore really who still use
like trans and gay as an insult or
actions actually on the left
they use it as an insult all the time
they use it in a pejorative way
about their opponents
you're only saying that because you're
gay you're trans
what exactly ned are you trying to imply
are you saying it's a bad thing
to identify though that way
you know what yes i am trans
fine
i'll go ahead yeah i'm i'm actually
trans which means that you can no longer
criticize me
and uh i have the
you know moral authority to talk about
these issues
we already know that i'm an lgbt
best-selling lgbt children's author i
don't think i need to remind you of that
so i've got all the points
uh mike says matt your airbnb rant makes
you sound like someone who uh still
takes a cab instead of uber now that's
that's uh that's that's an entirely
different thing okay so
airbnb versus hotels and then you've got
uber versus cab so
the
the cab experience
is certainly
um
uh worse than the uber experience and
the uber experience is often not that
great
but the cab industry somehow and you
could you almost have to respect it they
just have refused to update
improve anything at all
i mean you still get in the cab the cabs
themselves look like they're still from
the 90s and it's still just reeks of bo
and whereas in ubers it's only like 50
of the time do they reek of bo and just
the whole experience is pretty miserable
and awful and the cab is dirty and
everything they're not making any
attempt at all to compete with uber
they're just good they are sticking by
their guns you have to respect it but um
but it is certainly a worse experience
but just because something is newer
and has more technology behind it
doesn't automatically make it better
because then you go to airbnb versus
hotels and airbnb is the newer thing
but the hotel experience is on average
way better
i would say
a mcmahon says i cannot believe the pure
cowardice of this police officer was
giving orders the men under his command
should have ignored him their jobs
notwithstanding
well it's a tale of zola's time right
people using the i'm just following
orders excuse and we fight it here again
athena says joining the navy is my dream
after high school but after hearing this
is starting to happen i'm starting to
become unsure yeah i hear this from a
lot of a lot of younger people who are
thinking about joining the military now
aren't sure about it here from a lot of
parents
who
maybe would have loved the idea of their
sons joining the military and and now
aren't sure that's how i feel about it
you know i don't even like to
it feels bad to even say it out loud but
but the truth is that
no i don't want my sons to join the
military
as it stands right now
because for a number of reasons and but
one of them is that
now they're giving their lives over to
this and they're sacrificing their you
know
their liberty their ability you can't
just leave because you feel like it
and so that means that they're going to
be totally vulnerable
to all this stuff all the woke
indoctrination everything uh they're
signing up for that
and you they don't have the ability to
simply just leave
and then you add on to that the people
that we often have running the country
are going to take you know love to go on
these adventures overseas and send them
off to fight wars that we have nothing
to do with so
um yeah at this point that's just the
sad reality
let's see
uh dan says the cowardice is mostly the
result of the climate the police have to
work under the inhibitions and hesitancy
are being ingrained in an attempt to
curtail abuse unsolvable situation in my
opinion accepting
accept adopting self-defense culture and
incorporate
knowledge and training in every possible
way yeah there's a lot that goes into it
uh with with this you know what's what's
happening with with police and what
happened in uvalde
um and i hear a lot about the climate
that police have to work with
and work in
and i have a lot of sympathy for that
but that sympathy of course dries up
when you try to use that as an excuse
to sit safely in the hallway while while
19 children are executed because nothing
can excuse that
and the anti-police climate and culture
certainly doesn't excuse that in fact
it's quite the opposite now you're
creating more of that you're making that
climb in that culture even worse through
your own actions
um but overall we live in a in it's not
just with police but in general we we
live in a culture that um
encourages cowardice and selfishness
you know
c.s lewis wrote about this
we make men without chess and expect of
them virtue and sacrifice and that's
what we're doing in our culture now we
breed cowardice
and self-centeredness
narcissism on purpose and then we're
shocked when we see as lewis wrote
cowards in our midst
um
and april says it's a mixed bag either
way airbnb or hotels ask someone working
at a hotel how clean everything is doubt
you'll like the answer matt no i'm not
going to ask that that is a question i
will not ask and i don't want to know
because ignorance is bliss april
well the sweet baby gang has proven yet
again that its financial loyalty knows
no bounds the virtue signal patch sold
out again yesterday there are a lot of
virtuous people out there because uh and
you know i'm one of them because my
generosity knows no bounds we are going
to be restocking the patch to give you
another opportunity to seize the moral
high ground head over to my swag shack
dailywire.com shop to claim your virtual
signal patch and the indulgent sense of
self-satisfaction that comes with it
today also june has been a massive month
over here at the daily wire with tons of
new content being released and if you
haven't seen it all yet go to
dailywire.com to watch our new summer
blockbuster tara the prairie starring
mma fighter turned actress gina carano
cancelled by disney then uncanceled by
us this woman is absolutely unstoppable
on camera and off and we're not the only
ones who feel that way
yesterday in an op-ed for the daily mail
megan mccain praised gina for her
fearlessness and defying the corporate
hollywood snake and joining us in our
fight to take back the culture in the
article megan writes quote the daily
wire have created a new avenue for
artists that has the potential and
audience backing to allow them to create
on their own terms to gina that's the
future well it's the future for us too
which is why the daily wire is in high
gear on every front with fearless
documentaries like what is a woman
exposing the distorted gender ideas
poisoning our kids minds it's also
series like debunked that army with all
the facts you need to counter common
leftist claims all of this is yours when
you become a member at the daily wire
just go to dailywire.com walsh use
codewalsh for 25 off your new membership
right now now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today it's my great pleasure to cancel
maybe not for the first time the tsa um
as you know the so-called transportation
security administration was invented in
2001 by george w bush who responded to
911 by creating dozens of useless
government agencies and launching two
wars on the other side of the world
911 was itself in large part a failure
of government 19 guys from middle from
the middle east slowly but surely worked
on their plan to stage the worst attack
on american soil in our history they
planned and trained for it in our own
country
and none of our intelligence or law
enforcement agencies did a thing to stop
it and they all knew that some kind of
big attack was coming
but there was no competent or organized
effort to figure out what it would be or
to prevent it the attack was entirely
preventable by the agencies that already
existed and through the security
processes that were already in place but
all of them failed and they failed
spectacularly they failed in every
possible way
and as punishment for the government's
failure
it only grew larger
gave itself more money granted itself
more power
if a dozen government agencies failed to
stop 911 the thinking went let's just
form a dozen more
while doing absolutely nothing at all to
fix the problems in the first dozen
and that's if these security screenings
we already had in place didn't work
let's just make the security process
more complicated and extravagant and
inconvenient
while doing absolutely nothing at all to
address the reasons for its failure in
the first place this is the way the
government operates
and that is why the tsa was created
the agency now has some 47 000 employees
stretched out across all 50 states in
the latest federal budget it was awarded
10 billion
and this is a 1.4 billion dollar
increase over the previous year overall
over the past 20 years the tsa has used
up about 140 billion dollars of taxpayer
money
and that's to say nothing of all the
many billions of hours of lost
productivity
the tsa has eaten up while we're all
standing around in line doing the
security theater hokey pokey while being
sexually molested by overweight
rent-a-cops
but look on the bright side
this whole charade might be grotesquely
wasteful and pointless and gratuitous
and it might be a blatant infringement
on your constitutional rights for agents
of the state to treat you like a
suspected terrorist just because you
want to board an airplane but at least
they're keeping us safe
that is they're keeping us safe from
liquids gels and aerosols
which is essentially all the tsa
actually does now
they build giant collections of
confiscated lotion bottled water and
tubes of toothpaste
they can't explain why they're
confiscating these items
they can't tell you exactly what risk is
posed by a can of deodorant that exceeds
the arbitrary cutoff of 3.4 ounces but
whatever the threat is we're being saved
from it
and the tsa they're quite proud of this
yesterday lisa farbstein who is the tsa
spokeswoman and somehow has the perfect
name for a tsa spokeswoman gleefully
bragged on twitter about all of the
oversized gels and lotions the tsa had
confiscated at just one airport in
syracuse over a three-day span here's
her tweet she said
along with a picture of their um of
their winnings
display of oversized liquids gels and
aerosols that travelers had in their
carry-on bags the syracuse airport tsa
checkpoint in a three-day span the limit
for liquids through a checkpoint is 3.4
ounces
now as you can see there our protectors
of the tsa heroically saved us from
countless bottles of deer park water
several containers of vaseline um a
collection of toothpaste tubes four or
five snow globes somehow and even one
jar of chunky peanut butter the last one
may have been a terrorist planning a
mass attack against people with peanut
allergies
you never know
and hopefully the peanut butter bandit
was detained by the tsa and then shipped
down to gitmo for interrogation we could
only hope all in all i think we can
agree that this hall is uh certainly
worth 140 billion dollars
now i said before that nobody can
explain why these items aren't allowed
through security
it's true that nobody at the tsa can
explain it
but there is a reason ostensibly
the real reason why we spend billions of
dollars and billions of hours collecting
and throwing away bottles of water and
jars of vaseline is that in 2006 a
suspected terrorist in britain named
abdullah ahmed ali
was caught on surveillance surveillance
cameras drilling a hole into a bottle of
water which he potentially intended to
fill with explosive liquid and then
potentially wanted to detonate on a
plane and he was arrested before the
plan could be taken into action
and so nothing actually happened but
that's the reason why you can't take
your dasani through security it's
because one suspected terrorist in
another country 15 years ago drilled a
hole into a water bottle
same thing with shoes by the way
like one guy
years and years ago
um got onto a plane with a bomb in his
shoe
and it didn't detonate
and so everyone has to take their shoes
off now forever
by the way the tsa screening the
security screening failed in that case
no they didn't even stop it
now of course if somebody did have an
explosive bottle of aquafina or an
explosive shoe and they wanted to kill a
bunch of people with it they could still
walk into any crowded area and
accomplish that task
in fact they could walk right into the
crowd crowded line at security and do it
because we're conveniently for the
terrorists we're bunching everyone
together in this one choke chokehold
just this one uh you know choke point
rather and it is kind of a choke hold
sometimes we're putting everybody there
and creating a perfect opportunity for
terrorists if they wanted to take
advantage of it
but we're spending 140 billion dollars
to make sure that they at least can't do
it on planes
well actually they can still do it on
planes because as an investigation in
2017 revealed and investigations before
that and after that have had the same
result tsa screenings have a failure
rate of over 50 percent
47 000 employees tens of billions of
dollars spent
and still these glorified mall cops fail
more than half of their
inspections and this leads to another
question
how many terrorist attacks has the tsa
actually prevented
yes they're wasting extraordinary
amounts of time and money yes they're
giving you uh they got you playing simon
says while they bark orders at you and
they have you strip off random items of
clothing for no reason uh yes this is
all humiliating and seemingly pointless
and intrusive but perhaps it's worth it
if they're actually preventing terrorist
attacks
who knows how many people are alive
today because of the efforts of the tsa
however half-assed those efforts might
be
well we do know actually
we know that the tsa has prevented
precisely zero terror attacks
zero
over 20 years in and there is no
evidence that the tsa has ever stopped
even one terror attack from taking place
they have not caught
one terrorist in 20 years not one
700 million people board flights in
america each year that's 14 billion over
the past 20 years
the tsa has therefore screened 14
billion people
not one of them was a terrorist
o for 14 billion so it's a review
the tsa is bad at its job
wasteful incompetent
there's no evidence that has ever
accomplished the one single thing it was
formed in order to accomplish
and for all that it got a 1.4 billion
raise this year
it's quite infuriating when you think
about it
but hey at least they got that jar of
crunchy peanut butter before somebody
really got hurt
and that guy should be eating creamy
peanut butter anyway what kind of freak
eats crunchy peanut butter
still we must say the tsa
and crunchy peanut butter are both
cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadowsky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor in chief and co-host of
morning wire on today's episode the
senate reaches a deal on gun control
consumers face even higher prices on
homes cars and food and the supreme
court defends using vouchers for
religious schools
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire